Macron qui s'est exprimé ce soir et il
assume pleinement la décision de Gabriel
Attal regardez on l'a pas encore
Emmanuel Macron il est avec Papa Ndiaye
il arrive après vous inquiétez pas voilà
ils sont ils ont pas la voir hein vous
inquiétez pas on va la voir ça arrive
dans un instant on a ni l'un qui est
avec nous 16 ans et on a son père mida
merci d'être là et je voudrais remercier
mon frérot qui me les a ramenés qui me
les amené voilà et voilà qui va venir
très vite dans l'émission juste on était
sur qui là qui voulait parler j'ai pas
eu regardez vos petites pancartes est-ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec la décision
de Gabriel Attal ou pas alors on a
Pascal de la tour du pain qui prend
jamais parti donc on lui a mis un
drapeau de la Suisse euh voilà ok voilà
donc Pascal doit-on du pain vous vous
dites quoi non non je dis juste pour
rester peut-être factuel en tout cas les
chiffres c'est vrai que les Français
majoritairement soutiennent la décision
de Gabriel Attal cette Français sur 10
en moyenne d'après un sondage et là mais
ce qui a poussé le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale à prendre ce type
de décision aujourd'hui c'est que depuis
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty on a
constaté au sein de l'Éducation dans les
écoles une montée une montée
considérable des atteintes à la laïcité
à peine Guy ne s'était pas prononcé
Gabrielle sur quoi il s'est pas rendu
condensé papa Ndiaye
ne s'était pas prononcé ça va ensemble
il y avait pas une décision prise
Gabriel Attal donc prends cette décision
qui est soutenue par une majorité de
Français soutenu Emmanuel Macron bien
sûr il vient de me diriger j'ai fini
avec papa c'est bon il lui a envoyé son
solde de tout compte c'est bon merci
c'est bon
gratuite
laïque et obligatoire nos enfants on
veut pas savoir d'où ils viennent ce
qu'ils pensent de quelle famille ils
sont c'est un élément de justice de la
maternelle jusqu'au baccalauréat
l'école est laïque et ça veut dire qu'il
n'y a pas la place pour les signes
religieux faut que les familles qui
voulaient mettre la Baya pour leur fille
ou les jeunes filles qui voulaient la
mettre comprennent ce pourquoi on le
fait c'est respectueux c'est
bienveillant c'est la laïcité là-dessus
on est largement chaque année une
religion mais dans l'école il y a pas de
place pour ces signes
voilà donc il était chez Hugo décrit un
excellent Hugo j'embrasse également
alors Gilles Verdez toi tu es pas
d'accord avec le président de la
République non ni avec Monsieur Attal
mais ça va aller quand même
il faut être clair serrer la Baya n'est
pas un vêtement religieux
pourquoi il t'arrête tout de suite donc
ça a été c'est un vêtement dont on sait
qu'il a été porté par les Bédouins qui
est officiel en Arabie Saoudite qui est
officiel en Iran d'ailleurs vous ne le
savez peut-être pas mais là-bas il y a
des voix pour essayer de commencer à
demander la fin de cette interdiction
évidemment que c'est une tenue
religieuse oui qu'elle soit aussi
culturelle culturelle et que elle soit à
la croisée de plusieurs chemins ça c'est
tout à fait possible et que la religion
musulmane soit quelque chose de beaucoup
plus complexe que ça évidemment on peut
pas réduire uniquement cette tenue
seulement à le fait que c'est une tenue
religieuse mais c'en est une c'est un
message politique ce n'est pas bien sûr
que si c'est une tenue qui est à la mode
qui est portée par les jeunes j'ai
l'impression que vous avez bien en tout
cas j'ai l'impression que vous allez
bien vous entendre tous les deux par les
jeunes filles je sens que je tiens un
duo voilà tu vois qui adore cette tenue
parce qu'elle est ample parce
qu'effectivement en ce moment elle est
très vendue de cacher leur forme et
elles aiment bien et moi j'en ai marre
pourquoi pourquoi
j'en ai marre
j'en ai marre de cette République où
l'on stigmatise les musulmans merci
qu'est-ce que vous allez faire qu'est-ce
que vous
allez
vous leur reprochez de
de d'opérer un repli communautaire vous
allez leur reprocher de ne pas chanter
la Marseillaise mais à force ils vont
dire que la République n'est plus à
l'heure donc revenez à la raison pensez
aux musulmans arrêtez-vous
Eric noir de l'islamisme sauf que je
sais pas si vous êtes plus idiocutile ou
l'inverse je sais pas je sais pas si
vous croyez à ce que vous dit
[Applaudissements]
es plus d'une oppression moi ça me fait
très plaisir
parce que vous êtes originaire d'Algérie
c'est ça alors je suis né en France de
parents algériens et c'est pas la police
je suis né en France
ça a été imposé par les pays du Golfe
via leur prédicateurs via leur prêcheurs
via leur technique dans doctrinement et
ça me fait beaucoup soutenir par les
frères
que tu soutiennent l'islam rigoriste qui
est en train de faire
il faut définitivement
et l'islam rigoriste il faut arrêter
tradition et religion c'est pour ça que
je disais que tout à l'accord c'était
peut-être plus complexe et on a la
chance la tenue elle est aussi on a la
chance en France on a la chance en
France contrairement à d'autres pays que
les bibliothèques sont gratuites
d'accord et qui a un endroit qui est
exceptionnel je savais pas ouais qui
s'appelle l'Institut du monde arabe où
il y a une magnifique bibliothèque où il
y a des bouquins de Lorient ne sont pas
d'accord
mais bizarrement bizarrement lorsqu'on
vous entend vous prenez toujours le côté
mal plutôt que ceux qui donnent
l'exemple non moi je dis juste une à
l'époque je vais te dire pas qu'on
mélange et j'arrive
le port de cette tenue est un symbole
politiquement religieux mais bien sûr
on a la chance d'avoir ni là et son papa
qui sont avec nous on est là tu as 16
ans cette année tu fais ta rentrée en
classe de première et ce soir tu es avec
nous car tu aimerais nous donner ton
avis sur la décision de Gabriel Attal
est-ce que déjà ça étonné
toi tu vas tu vas dans une école tu vas
avec cette tenue ou pas d'accord ça tu
as jamais posé de problème ça pose pas
de problème aux autres élèves bien
entendu au professeur
ça pose problème à personne et là toi tu
te dis comment tu vas faire demain en
fait ce que tu rentres demain en classe
oui donc demain comment tu vas je mets
un kimono
[Rires]
mais tu vas respecter la loi c'est ça
mais quand même ça va changer ton
quotidien pourquoi tu comprends pas tu
as vu on va on va voir le sondage dans
un instant tu vois quand tu comprends
pas ce qui disent qui comprennent la
décision de Gabriel Attal parce que
parce que l'abeille c'est une robe en
fait c'est pas une c'est pas un habit
religieux c'est une robe ça veut dire
robe en fait et
voilà c'est une robe
et donc toi ça te dérange parce que tu
te dis voilà si on j'ai pas le droit de
m'habiller comme je veux en fait tu
t'habilles comme ça tous les jours à
l'école non pas tous les jours non pas
tout le temps je m'habille des fois en
jogging quand je dis sport je me mets
pas toujours en mais j'aime bien
m'habiller comme ça vous êtes le papa de
Nina vous vous comprenez la décision
vous dites à votre fille on comprend la
mission ou est-ce que vous lui dites oui
je comprends c'est c'est inadmissible
moi je suis un père de famille comme de
très nombreux citoyens de ce pays qui a
une jeune fille qui m'a dit ma fille
décide de d'avoir une tenue
vestimentaire et tout à l'heure
j'entendais souvent que la République
arrive la République la République la
langue de la République française c'est
le français donc je comprends pas déjà
l'utilisation du terme à Bahia d'accord
pour avoir des origines de pays de
l'autre côté de la Méditerranée le mois
Bahia signifie tunique robe ok vous vous
portez ici après Miss camis c'est à dire
une chemise
le mokamisme
souvent les gens ne le savent pas le
chemise vient du mot camis et kamis une
chemise peut être court long d'accord
une ce qu'on appelle ici nabaïa c'est
une sémantique qui est mise en avant
d'accord par certaines personnes qui
voudraient impérativement donner un sens
religieux mais c'est qui qui décide de
ce qui est religieux ou pas en
République française l'état tout à
l'heure ce monsieur Naulleau rappelait
que l'État
ça a été laïque l'état n'indique pas et
n'a pas le droit de s'immiscer dans
l'organisation ou la définition de ce
qui est ou pas il a pour garantir
l'éducation à nos enfants à tous les
enfants de France donc moi je suis
choqué qu'on puisse alors que d'autres
n'ont rappelé on a des personnes
handicapées qui n'arrivent pas à se
déplacer dans les enseignements l'année
dernière je suis dans un quartier où le
deuxième jour de la rentrée tous les
professeurs étaient en grève parce que
quatre toilettes pour 800 élèves on a
des problèmes plus graves et ensuite il
faut dire une chose qui éclaire moi
c'est ma fille je la défendrai j'ai pas
envie que ma fille demain elle venait en
pleurant l'a dit elle s'habille comme
elle veut moi d'ailleurs quand elle
décide de mettre sa tenue en tant que
père j'ai rien à lui dire laisse-moi
jogging elle se met en jeans ce qu'elle
veut mais par contre que des hommes ici
bien puissent ici ou d'autres personnes
imposer une tenue vestimentaire en
expliquant c'est quoi le religieux ou
pas l'état déjà n'a pas le faire et
d'autant plus que moi c'est intéressant
moi je le dis si comme ça tout me le
sais ma fille si un jour elle arrive en
robe parce que je n'ai pas le mot
pourquoi on parle que du moi d'ailleurs
c'est pour dire c'est arabe c'est
étranger donc c'est musulmans c'est ça
ce que ça veut dire non non il faut dire
que c'est une robe est-ce qu'on peut
venir avec une robe ou pas vous et moi
on porte une barbe une barbe ça peut
être la mode ça peut être un style ça
peut aussi avoir un sens religieux alors
s'il y a des jeunes lycéens qui arrivent
à au lycée qu'est-ce qu'on va leur faire
comment on va déterminer si c'est
religieux ou pas monsieur les islamistes
d'accord pour vous non non monsieur je
parle de l'école monsieur Naulleau
monsieur nolo je parle de l'école vous
avez c'est les assistants
mais plutôt il y a aussi des
paternalistes qu'il faudrait aussi
parfois rappeler à l'ordre parce que
c'est important ça a l'air de vous
déranger non non pas du tout
de l'identité française moi je suis
attaché à l'identité comme nous on est
dans mes mesures
ça marche pas c'est vous réellement si
j'arrive ici c'est absolument là ici tu
cherches
que ça n'a rien à voir le nazisme
la laïcité c'est la différence on va
dire l'état est indifférent vis-à-vis de
tout le monde d'accord c'est votre
conception et d'ailleurs dans ce pays
c'est pas vous ni moi ni les ministres
ni les enseignants
vous avez anticipé ceux qui vont
déterminer monsieur réellement ce qui
est religieux on va dire
monsieur c'est tenu interdit c'est
religieux
pas du tout mais en même temps
terminé la réalité qu'avant avant tout
c'est la politesse et l'échange donc
laissez-moi terminer sinon on n'arrivera
pas il y a pas de dialogue c'est terminé
donc moi ce que je voulais dire c'est
que déjà c'est ma fille qui est ici moi
je vais la protéger sur son père comme
tous les papas on aime nos filles et
personne personne si ce n'est la loi qui
fixe qui fixe les règles et aujourd'hui
c'est pas une loi c'est une note une
note on va dire c'est tout en circulaire
c'est une note monsieur
circulaire alors si donc est-ce que
est-ce qu'elle aurait le droit demain
d'aller à l'école on a Baya où est-ce
que c'est ah oui mais c'est toute la
question
si ma fille se fait recaler c'est pas un
vêtements religieux d'ailleurs ma fille
porte le voile quand elle arrive avec la
loi d'accord tandis que je vous dis s'il
vous plaît ma fille elle décide de
porter le voile quand elle arrive à
l'école de la République moi je veux pas
qu'elle est dans des écoles
professionnelles je veux qu'elle ait de
l'école de la République là on forme des
citoyens parce que demain ma fille
puisse servir son pays
d'accords de journée
je les connais pas moi je vous parle de
ma vie qui a 16 ans je veux qu'elle
finisse son bac et qu'elle réussisse
monsieur aucun rapport avec l'islam
radical mais le fait que les Frères
musulmans est soutenu très clairement
cette tenue
là vous parlez à une jeune fille
attendez vous parler à son temps à vous
pas du tout est-ce que toutes les
je vous explique je vous explique une
chose on verra ce que dit le Conseil
d'État en attendant laissez-moi finir
s'il vous plaît dans tous les cas de
figure moi si ma fille et sa maman elle
fait l'objet d'une interdiction de
pénétrer dans l'enceinte de la
République c'est très simple ah ben on
se rend auprès du commissariat on dépose
plainte pour rupture de d'égalité face
au service public et pour discrimination
on ramène ça sur le terrain du pénal
d'accord et on verra ce que justice dira
et ensuite il y a des tribunaux au
niveau administratifs qui seront saisi
et c'est eux qui diront si c'est un
vêtement religieux ou pas mais au-delà
de ça vous vous estimez que c'est pas
religieux
qui va vous choquer dans la religion
musulmane il n'y a pas de vêtements dits
religieux d'accord entendez bien ce que
je vous dis il y a pas une règle dans la
région musulmane il y a des dogmes il y
a des façons de prier mais il n'y a pas
il n'y a pas une tenue vestimentaire qui
est dite
je vais vous dire pourquoi je vais vous
dire pourquoi c'est pas l'islam qui
impose
je m'en fous de l'islamiste moi je suis
musulman d'accord je suis musulman
d'accord ma fille aussi et je peux vous
dire par là monsieur vous me posez très
bonne question entendez ce que je vais
vous dire je vous écoute parce que je
suis là aussi pour défendre ma fille qui
pour nous pour moi et pour mon épouse va
certainement faire l'objet
d'une attitude d'une décision qui pour
nous est discriminatoire comment on va
décider qu'est-ce que entre guillemets
une Arabia ou pas d'accord parce que une
abeille est une pourquoi ils ont pas dit
au fait dans le 7 note là les robes sont
interdites parce qu'on sait pas
tellement qu'on peut pas interdire ça
existe pas la police
et je termine juste en disant moi je
suis musulman d'accord
ça n'existe pas de vêtements proprement
dit religieux ça n'existe pas vous allez
dans tous les pays où il y a
l'islamation
Monsieur donc moi donc ma fille est une
islamiste c'est ça monsieur mais je me
dis que l'islamisme décide qu'il y a des
vêtements religieux d'accord à l'islam
mais l'islam
c'est l'islamisme qui décide que les
femmes doivent être voilées sinon elles
sont torturées violées
françaises des hommes ou des décideurs
décident de déshabiller des hommes qui
ont choisi vos raisons d'avoir
ça doit pas être évident pour vous parce
que parle de vous exactement
après effectivement Gilles était
absolument à côté de la plaque en juin
je constate qu'il est à côté de la
plaque en septembre par pure de magie
j'imagine alors moi c'est une bonne
émission toi
[Rires]
tu vas lui dire dans un instant on se
retrouve dans un instant pour la fin de
ce débat il doit être 3 minutes et puis
on parlera bien sûr de cette ennemi le
mystère Émile et Pierre Palmade cette
histoire est-il allé en boîte de newcast
tout le monde dans la parité on aura les
révélations du directeur de la
discothèque qui avait dit qu'il était
pas allé il va nous dire la vérité ici
dans un instant et Gilles t'inquiète pas
que des amis ici à tout de suite
[Applaudissements]